[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
dans laquelle nous allons traiter de
deux grands sujets d'actualité
l'un qui ne concerne pas directement la
france mais qui concerne tous les
français évidemment et tout le monde
entier ce sont les élections américaines
une élection absolument folle vous le
savez et puis un deuxième sujet qui nous
intéresse tout ce sont les rapports
entre les hommes et les femmes avec deux
courants qui semble un peu divergentes
affirmations du genre l'autre de
confusion des genres justement on va en
parler tout au long de cette émission
avec florence mercadé ce qu'est mon jour
la casse au barreau de versailles avec
stéphane mon sens aujourd'hui vous êtes
professeur à l'université de versailles
saint quentin ancien doyen de la faculté
de droit
et puis avec nous jean charles lajoie
dit bonjour bonjour vous êtes vous êtes
éditeur anne-charlotte bezina pardon
j'aurais dû commencer par vous suis
désolé bonjour patrice faye maître de
conférences à l'université de rouen
vincent couronne bonjour bonjour patrice
le fondateur de ce tueur lignières vous
êtes aussi à france info
vous faites aussi un blog sur les idées
reçues sur l'europe
et puis nous avons une invitée je suis
ravi de recevoir qui est annie porter
bonjour bonjour tout le monde
alors vous êtes vous êtes américaine
vous votez aux états unis et vous êtes
en plus la représentante du parti
démocrate en france c'est exactement ça
va tromper c'est très bien donc
eh ben je suis ravi de vous avoir
puisque évidemment on va parler cette
premier sujet de cette émission de cette
élection folle
le débat est de le combattre up by donne
[Musique]
alors il ya ya une plein d'événements
cette campagne ait eu notamment le fait
que trump soient atteints de l'aco vide
kid les vraisemblablement alors
aujourd'hui on l'entend partout dire que
il est immunisée qu'ils ne risquent rien
qu'il a vaincu le virus cette trempe
super héros c'est un peu ça 1 me porter
vous lis bien je ne sais pas si vous
avez vu l'article est sorti dans new
york times ce week-end mais il paraît
que cet homme qui est en représentation
en permanence qui joue le rôle de
président comme s'ils étaient dans une
télé réalité est plutôt que de gouverner
pour de vrai il voulait sortir de
l'hôpital ouvrir sa chemise et avoir un
t-shirt superman en dessous et la
mentalité d'un enfant de 5 ans en par
les bras m'en tombent
plus rien ne pourrait me surprendre mais
justement on a l'impression que vous
avez raison et mis en scène ce côté
super héros 22 vide et c est ce que
est ce que dans l'opinion américaine ça
peut un peu changé des choses ou pas je
vais vous demander à vous aimer porter
et puis peut-être à 50 d'entre vous
ensuite je pense que ça a déjà changé
les choses pour les américains parce que
le fait que 30 soit atteint lui même de
qu'ovide il est le symbole de l'échec de
sa gestion de cette crise du fiasco
que sait on a quatre concentre la
population mondiale on a 25 % des décès
donc il ya forcément un problème dans la
façon dont il a géré d'irène pas gérer
cette crise
et vous savez aux états unis on peut
voter à l'avance les bureaux de vote
s'ouvrent dès fois quelques semaines à
la vente avant la date de l'élection et
les gens votent également par
correspondance il ya déjà 10 millions
d'américains qui ont voté pour le 3
novembre prochain
c'est juste cinquante fois plus que
d'habitude les gens sont très motivés
pour voter dans cette élection et je
veux dire quoi
parce que l'habitation et des deux côtés
énormément de gens qui n'ont jamais voté
il y a des gens des jeunes qui votent
pour la première fois il y à une
mobilisation extrême dans les
communautés de communes haute et de
couleurs les noirs et les hispaniques
aux états unis et ces gens vont voter en
masse contre dans le train tu donc pour
joe bada et mme germaine bezina du père
comment vous regardez cette campagne vue
de fons vie de france je trouve qu'on a
le sentiment que les états unis font
toujours dans le spectacle et c'est un
peu ce qui est
totalement original dans la manière de
gérer la campagne présidentielle aux
états unis par rapport à ce que
constitutionnellement nous avons
l'habitude d'avoir en france et
politiquement il ya il ya ce côté
débridé de toute façon très passionnel
et on a de plus en plus en france une
forme d'un plan de ce type de
personnalisation de la campagne mais ça
ne donne pas du tout la même chose on a
ici à mon avis la clé de cette
personnalisation avec un donald trump
qui se prend pour une figure de super
héros et qui finalement est lui-même en
train de se battre contre ses propres
échecs et la figure de joe biden qui va
être ok l'on va reprocher justement ce
côté plus calmes et qui dans les
dernières semaines rentrer dans la
campagne avec un côté plus combative
donc il y à il ya en effet quelque chose
d'un peu spectaculaire à regarder
toujours une campagne américaine et
c'est vrai que c'est ce dernier épisode
de lakovic 19 à mon avis rajoute encore
au piment de cette élection
même si à mon avis cette crise que
donald trump et été infectés ou non
cette crise sanitaire a été un des
déterminants de cette de cette élection
puisque il ya eu une question de
légitimité à jouer pour donald trump qui
lui coûte peut-être cette réélection
auxquelles il croyait temps et auquel
peut-être quelques mois auparavant avant
la crise sanitaire il aurait même pu
prétendre à mon avis dans l'opinion donc
hier il ya vraiment un changement par
rapport à 7,7 coville 19 et c'est aussi
la première campagne qu'on vit
directement enfin la campagne aussi
populaire qu'on vit directement à la
suite de cette crise et on se rend
compte que finalement les gouvernants il
joue quelque chose ou voit en france
notamment avec la judiciarisation d'un
beaucoup de plaintes pénales pour la
gestion du coffee on a le sentiment que
le peuple a besoin de réponses et on
voit bien que cette crise sanitaire elle
est aussi une crise politique finalement
vous avez raison d'ailleurs avant la
crise sanitaire
c'est vrai que l'économie américaine se
portait plutôt bien et que train péter à
ses favoris dont pour sa réélection et
la crise a tout changé mais
peut-être florence stéphane vincent ou
jean-charles c'est vrai quand on regarde
cette élection américaine de loin on a
l'impression qu'elle a écrite par des
scénaristes tellement tellement elle est
tellement il ya de rebondissements de
suspense de chose qui arrive qu'on
attendait pas est-ce qu'on n'est pas
dans une sorte de domophobie de symbole
de ce qu'est la politique aujourd'hui
c'est à dire une fiction presque que les
scénaristes peuvent prendre leur stylo
est juste prendre des notes en ils n'ont
pas besoin d'inventer grand chose ce qui
est moi ce qui me terrifie un peu c'est
que il sait que allah il est en perte de
vitesse et qui risquent de perdre et en
fait après moi le chaos et donc il est
en train d'entraîner ce il entraîne en
train d'entraîner ce pays dans le chaos
ce qui a quand même aussi des
répercussions sur l'ensemble des pays du
monde et nous aussi d'ailleurs je trouve
ça vraiment extrêmement grave parce
qu'on sait pas il lâche toi je pense
qu'il va pas lâcher sa défaite qui va
pas vouloir la reconnaître il faut lier
encore là il a de la maison blanche et
donc les scénaristes vont pouvoir
continuer à prendre des notes parce que
je sais pas ce qui va comment ça va se
dérouler mais je crains un peu que les
gens prennent les armes et j'entendais
d'ailleurs un écrivain samedi matin qui
expliquait qu' on trouve tout cartouches
lorsqu'il ya tellement de personnes qui
se sont attelés à un nom de cartouches
de munitions wii la wii
non mais voilà les cartouches conviés
dans les armes mais tellement tellement
d'années s'est jeté il ya plus de
cartouches inc
c'est quand même extrêmement inquiétant
et des cartouches d'encre parce que
disons qu'on est des notes mais nos étés
un de cartouches d'armes et ça fait
vraiment inquiétante
on va avoir des gens déjà déjà les gens
sont déchirés entre eux les amis aux
états unis qui nous disent mais je pense
que madame va pouvoir en parler bien
mieux que moi mais qui disent qu'il ya
une haine entre les gens qui est
dramatique famille de cette amérique
divisés mais sur la compagne de stéphane
mais c'est vrai que c'est bon il vient
de la télé réalité mais il ya un peu de
saint-pois y ait un peu de la
fictionnalisation de la paix quand même
moi ce qui me ce qui me marque qui nous
touche aussi un ce qui se passe aux
etats unis la bienvenue à toi forcément
même même mais même à titre affectif
lien il ya un lien un lien culturel
historique tellement fort entre nous que
ça ne peut pas nous laisser indifférents
mais je rejoins florence moi ce qui me
fallait dire ça ne m'inquiète pas au
fond parce que je crois que la
démocratie étasunienne est une
démocratie extrêmement robuste et aux
états unis la démocratie était déjà
confortablement installé au moment où en
france celle-ci n'était que n'était
encore des halles ou balbutiante mais de
voir à quel point cette démocratie
historiquement politiquement
juridiquement très robuste très
enracinée peut se trouver du jour au
lendemain fragilisé au point que on
vient à évoquer la possibilité pour un
président de ne pas reconnaître sa
défaite
à l'instar de n'importe quelle
république bananière de n'importe quel
système autoritaire ou pseudo
autoritaire de démocratie libérale que
sais-je encore que cela se passe aux
etats unis d'amérique moi je suis quand
même assez fasciné de voir à quel point
le considère comme la plus grande
démocratie du monde au fonds je crois
que ça l'est
de voir à quel point les choses ne sont
jamais acquises est très fragile
fragilisé par par cette gangrène
populiste qui prend diverses formes
mais mais mais qui est une véritable
véritable cancer démocratique en tout
cas ultra libéralisme qui est développé
par lui aussi fragilise la démocratie
quand on voit l'augmentation du nombre
de pauvres de chômeurs c'est une
démocratie qui semble enfin lui la
transfo lille la fragilise au point qu
il oppose les gens et il appauvrit toute
une partie de la population qui n'était
pas à ce point de pauvreté aussi alors
vincent couronne est peut-être terminée
avec jean charles lajoie demi pour voir
peut-être un son différent je ne sais
pas
vincent couronne d'abord oui oui pas
nous regarde les frais de campagne et on
parle à un petit peu de fiction parce
que je sais pas si vous vous souvenez de
cette série américaine qui s'appelait à
la maison blanche
l'anglais the west wing qui avait une
sorte de qui a raconté un petit peu le
les aventures d'un président démocrate
d'ailleurs et qui avait une sorte de
prescience parce que on avait vu que pas
mal des choses qui avait été envisagé
dans cette série c'était ensuite réalisé
avec la présidence de barack obama dont
quelque chose assez intéressant après ça
cette série plutôt optimiste sur le
pouvoir américain n'a eu à 11h40 qui est
là pour le coup vision totalement
cataclysmique et chaotique du pouvoir
américain
là aussi un président démocrate barack
obama à l'époque avait dit que d'une
bonne partie de ce qui était dans cette
série c'est malheureusement vrai sur la
politique américaine
on a aujourd'hui donald train je me
demande en fait quelle sera la tonalité
de la prochaine série politique
américaine est ce que ce sera plutôt de
celle de sauvegarde en pire parce
qu'aujourd'hui
trump a montré qui est allé au delà dao
sur carte ou est ce qu'elle sera plutôt
de la tonalité de à la maison blanche
et dans ces cas-là un apaisement et
probablement de meilleurs jours pour les
états unis dont l'algérie une chose pour
rebondir sur les propos de florence des
américains ont qu à se renseigner auprès
d'eux des gens de champigny sur marne
visiblement tombée des armes n'est pas
hyper difficile partout 1 c'est déjà les
premières choses
deuxièmement je me méfie comme un tout
petit peu pour être plus sérieux de la
l'unanimité de l'unanimisme total sur
trame qui était que les arguments sont
souvent un peu con vrai c'est à dire que
eux
là on en est même à sortir le livre de
sa nièce qui visiblement n'a aucun
intérêt
on sort n'importe quoi pour abattre
trappe et je trouve tout ça ça manque un
peu d'intelligence et là je me dis après
la déception va être énorme parce que on
s'attaque tellement à trump est d'abord
nous en tant que français
de façon assez curieuse mais mais les
américains ils ont bien raison en sata 4
1 mais j'ai l'impression que on oublie
un peu le candidat joe biden qu'est ce
que propose ce ticket que va-t-il faire
qu'est-ce que ça va changer pour les
américains il représentait une sorte de
rêve en france en kabbale et les
démocrates et forcément génial et c'est
sûrement mais quel est vraiment le
programme qu'il est vraiment la
différence qui est qu'est ce que jobs
ait de nous apporter j'ai peur que le en
admettant que tu rames soient battus que
le lendemain soit un peu triste
on l'a fait eh ben on va demander on va
demander à la représentante du parti
démocrate ce que ça changerait peut-être
d'élections dubaï d'autres d'abord
peut-être d'apaiser peut-être un peu les
choses mais je pense qu il est vrai
qu'en france on voit beaucoup beaucoup
de reportages sont trompés très peur
très peur sur bayonne aux etats unis ce
n'est pas du tout la même chose
et dans notre propre communication des
démocrates à l'étranger en france on a
compris très très rapidement que ce
n'était pas la peine de faire des pubs
négatives sur 30 tout le monde le
déteste déjà on n'a pas besoin de le
redire donc on essaie de mettre en avant
le programme de baden programme son
histoire personnelle le fait que ce soit
un homme intègre que ce soit un homme
empathie qui a vécu énormément de deuil
dans sa vie qui me permet de comprendre
les vrais problèmes des américains
et il a un programme très riche déjà
rien que pour le coc vide il ya une
liste longue comme ça de tout ce qui
fera et qu'il arrive pour endiguer enfin
cette pandémie qui ne cesse de grimper à
l'écart monte tous les jours on a plus
mille morts par jour
unis cinquante mille nouveaux cas alors
qu on devrait autour de 10 milles
maximum donc qu'à sayat le climat il y a
justement les inégalités de revenus
aujourd'hui vous avez plus de gens et on
se sont inscrits au chômage et qui ont
voté pour rome en 2016 mais alors
justement vous vous dites voilà il ya
une sorte de rejet de trappes
mais ce que disait florence mercadé
choqué tout à l'heure et qui nous semble
assez vrai c'est qu'on a l'impression
nous vu d'ici que l'amérique n'a jamais
été autant déchiré qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est aussi votre
sentiment
c'est effectivement très très très
divisé et il suffit de regarder la
représentation dans les deux chambres
où en est quasiment à 50 50 à mon avis
ça va bientôt changer
mais l'a pour l'instant c'est vrai que
c'est il ya les clivages assez assez
forte mais malheureusement 30 à
encourager ce clivage il a encouragé
il encourage même la violence dont on
parlait tout à l'heure avec le manque de
balle pour coller pour les délais les
lézards moeurs aux états unis c'est vrai
et beaucoup de gens très bien sa vie en
à cette période un peu étrange entre la
fin de l'élection et le jour de
l'investiture du prochain président qui
sera le 20 janvier 2021 à midi et
pendant ce mois et demi deux mois il
peut se passer plein de choses à cette
attente et il ya beaucoup de gens qui
s'inquiètent pour ce que 30 est capable
de faire serait capable de faire s'il
perd il y avait les oui il ya d'ailleurs
le mythe du chaos est un habitat
important et aux états unis et il y
avait là vous voyez tout à l'heure la
photo de la une du times et que vous
aviez voulu florence mercadé et qui est
assez symbolique de 2 à 1
pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans
cette recette et j'aimerais bien qu'ils
voilà qui passe la porte comme ça
calmement alors évidemment trump est
atteint du virus
il a 74 ans il est en surpoids weiden à
78 ans bientôt
du coup il ya peut-être l'importance des
vice-présidents de n'a jamais été aussi
forte qu'aujourd'hui et les deux
candidats sont mike pence ce qui est
déjà vice président et kamala harris qui
est la colistière de baden des et
d'ailleurs rien un débat vous devez
regarder un et porter le débat entre les
deux vice présidents oh oui je les
regardais et je n'ai pas mal pas mal
commenté depuis oui oui elle raconte
raconte édouard votre votre sentiment
d'habitude aux états unis le
vice-président n'est pas aussi important
que ça en big toujours canton choix en
comptant choisi son colistier ou sa
colistière il faudrait que ce soit
quelqu'un qui ne nuit pas au candidat
principal et en général on fait pas trop
attention sauf quand il y en a une comme
ça rappelle qu'ils nuisent vraiment là
tout d'un coup on s'intéresse beaucoup
elle est bas il m'a dit lui même et il
est au courant du fait qu'il a 45 ans de
service public derrière lui il se dit
lui-même le candidat de la transition
donc à mars n'a que 55 ans qui très
jeune en politique
et ils pensent ils envisagent vraiment
de passer la main ça m'étonnerait
beaucoup par exemple nous faisons pour
un deuxième mandat en titrant 82 ans
oui oui c'est sûr qu'il va faire mais
s'il est élu il fera que mandat et on
parle même du fait qu' il pourrait
passer de la main même au cours de ce
mandat
enfin ça c'est ça c'est que c'est une
hypothèse qu'on verra ça dépend toujours
des tas de santé ça dépend de beaucoup
de choses
les davis près
peut-être une certaine magie là c'est
vrai que ce système du président vice
président il faut peut-être l'expliquer
c'est un peu différent vice président
c'est pas un premier ministre du tout
comme on a ici en france alors pas du
tout vous avez raison c'est une
spécificité des états unis c'est à dire
que on est mis un petit peu comme nous
en france nous avons par exemple
l'élection de nos députés
c'est à dire que du coup nous n'avons
pas un scrutin de liste c'est un scrutin
dit uninominal avec un seul nom mais il
ya une forme de suppléance qui est
organisée c'est à dire que vous ne lisez
pas une seule personne est une personne
et son remplaçant un système qu'on a en
quelque sorte pour les députés français
et aux états unis donc ce vice président
il a vraiment au premier titre dans la
constitution ce rôle de remplaçant c'est
à dire que c'est une manière pour la
constitution des états-unis d'incarner
le président jusque dans la continuité
de l'état c'est à dire même si ce
président a un empêchement et malade
décède brutalement et bien on aura
quelqu'un pour en quelque sorte prendre
la suite donc c'est pour ça que ce vice
président est à la fois peu important
parce que ça n'est pas du tout un
premier ministre n'est pas quelqu'un qui
gouvernera si le président est ton poste
et est en bonne santé mais c'est à la
fois cette continuité l'appendice en
quelque sorte du président qui
pourraient continuer à gouverner s'il
lui arrivait quelque chose donc c'est à
la fois la continuité de ce président
tout en étant complètement dans son
ombre puisque pour une présidence qui se
passe bien
la vice présidence elle est complètement
nul voila
voilà la spécificité de ce vice
président néanmoins c'est pas une
fonction qui est complètement
inintéressante et auquel les américains
sont aux sont assez peu confrontés parce
que ce vice présidente peut avoir aussi
des fonctions à l'étranger par exemple
être mandaté la démission montre voilà
exactement quelques missions et il a une
importance socio niveau du sénat qui est
président le senor présidence et d'une
présidence un peu
oui on aurait presque honorifique 1 une
fonction très secondaire mais qui peut
avoir son importance pour la continuité
de l'état américain mais porte est-ce
qu'il ya des faux ça dépend aussi de la
personne et des faillites deux choses
qui sont importantes c'est la
personnalité du vice-président inakis
sont imposés il y en a qui sont restés
je pense âge c'est pas qu'elle qui était
le vice-président de bush qui était un
peu un impôt idiot d'ailleurs mais enfin
qu'on n'a jamais entendu ça n'a jamais
entendu parler et puis il ya des
vice-présidents qui deviennent ensuite
des candidats qui ne viennent pas faut
ensuite des présidents qui sont donc
très bien avec le président donc qui ont
plus de missions comme comme al gore
avec clinton par exemple c'est quoi
l'histoire de ses vice présidents
en france nous avait on dit souvent il
ya une malédiction du premier ministre
qui ne peut jamais devenir président de
la république parce qu'on ne l'a jamais
eu comme ça mais aux états unis ça
dépend il ya des vice présidents pour
qui ça marche et d'autres pour qui ça
n'a pas marché c'est tout à fait exact
on a eu par exemple récemment al gore
qui était qu'il y avait quelques uns des
premiers vice-présidents qui avait un
vrai rôle avec l'environnement enfin
simpson lui avait missionné pour pas mal
de choses alors que les autres le rôle
si plutôt d'attendre ou bien d'assister
aux en fermant à l'étranger al gore qui
était vice-présidente de fois et qui a
échoué à devenir président vous avez
d'autres comme nixon qui était le vice
président ben ali nawa il a perdu une
première fois elle gère pas une erreur
devenu président vous avez johnson et ce
budget dont tout le monde se souvient de
les conditions dramatiques dans lequel
elle budget est devenu président en
prêtant serment dans l'avion air force
one alors que kennedy
mais elle budget a quand même fait
beaucoup beaucoup de choses plus tard
pour les droits civiques et il était un
vice-président important on dit que le
vice président le plus puissant était
déchaîné le vice président de baseball
et puis je vais vous poser une colle ya
quand même un vice président dans
l'histoire des états unis est devenu
président en se présentant contre le
président qui l'a servi
c'était un très très longtemps
ah oui parce que il faut dire qu'au
début le vice présidente de semble-t-il
un était celui qui arrivé deuxième à
l'élection
c'est vrai qu'au début les règles
n'étaient pas le même dans les mêmes
tons qu'il pouvait y avoir un tandem de
gens qui était de 2-2 un républicain et
un démocrate par exemple oui exactement
les parties ça fait pas comme ça à
l'époque mais john adams s'est vu
imposer comme vice président thomas
jefferson
voilà quatre ans déjà personnes s'est
présenté contre adobe qui voulait être
élu et c'est déjà personnes qui
passaient donc c'est la seule fois dans
l'histoire américaine et un
vice-président a battu son propre
président et puis il ya comme choses un
peu étonnant il ya aussi de gerald ford
qui est devenu président sans avoir été
vice président sans avoir été élu par la
force des choses
et puisque puisque le vice président qui
préside et avaient été condamnés et qui
est devenu président vont ils sont
devenus présidents mais dans la moitié
ont pris ce rôle parce que le président
était mort exercice oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais c'est vrai que cette histoire
assez ses patientes celle de ses de
cette histoire politique américaine
d'une grande démocratie et on faisait
allusion à jefferson
c'est à l'époque nous n'étions pas nous
ont demandé si alors justement
l'importance des vice-présidents est ce
qu'on peut dire comme un mot ipad
quand même qu'on découvre qui est un
type assez ambigu parce qu'il est c'est
un c'est un conservateur qui dit je peux
je peux pas déjeuner tout seul avec une
femme pour ne pas céder à la tentation
et qui en même temps soutient un
président qui disait quand on est une
star on peut prendre les femmes par la
chatte
c'est quand même assez non mais c'est
quand même assez ambigu comme position
assez contradictoire non la question
êtes vous si vous voulez mais il est
vrai que mike pence et un homme plein
période paradoxe vous la corde
il a été gouverneur de l'état de
l'indiana à l'époque de l'épidémie du
sida dans les années 80 et les connu
pour avoir totalement raté la réponse à
la crise du sida et il ya des milliers
de morts il n'aurait pas dû avoir lieu
il n'aurait pas eu lieu si quelqu'un
d'autre avec gouverner parce que mike
pence est quelqu'un de profondément
homophobes et c'est vrai que
personnellement je n'ai jamais compris
comment il peut être à côté d'un homme
qui est tout sauf qui n'a aucun des
valeurs chrétiens soit disant que pence
on boucle ça dont on peine c'est la
promotion vincent / / / kamala harris ou
mike pence
ah oui mais moi je pense que ce débat
entre les vice présidents c'est
intéressant parce que je pense que
c'était ça le vrai débat de la
présidentielle le débat en réalité n'a
rien apporté d'intéressant à sofia en
savoir un peu plus sur le jusqu'au
boutisme de la personnalité de trump
mais mais mais cessons 2 2 personnages
qui nous faut quand même bien suivre
beaucoup plus que pour les précédentes
élections
et c'est vrai que mike pence et un
effectivement sur lui en particulier est
un personnage assez assez étonnant bon
écoutez je vois pas je pense que je suis
assez d'accord et ce qui a été dit
notamment par amy porter sur sur sur
l'incohérence entre la position de celle
de trump moi ce qui m'inquiète un peu
avec mike pence c'est que c'est un peu
la porte d'entrée aussi des évangéliques
au pouvoir fédéral américain
il y à un article assez intéressant dans
le monde d'hier sur justement le pouvoir
les évangéliques et et leur capacité à
pouvoir mobiliser l'électorat pour
permettre la réélection de l'unc trump
et je vois quand vous dites patrice
effectivement que my peine c'est
quelqu'un qui ne veut pas s'asseoir à la
table d'une femme pour éviter la
tentation etc on revoit la ici en fait
chez ces personnes là des tendances à ce
que notre président la république en
france emmanuel macron appelle une forme
de séparatisme
c'est à dire le fait que au nom de
valeurs religieuses en fait on refuse en
réalité tout un tas de deux rapports
sociaux etc et chez les évangéliques aux
états unis il ya quelque chose d'un peu
un peu comment dire qu'il peut faire un
peu peur et quand on voit la montée en
puissance de cette communauté religieuse
qui va devenir très rapidement la
première aux états unis voilà essais et
puis en plus de ça la tendance et il
faut rajouter à mélanger la religion et
le politique
je sais c'est chez ces personnes là où
sam
oui je voulais juste que revenir sur une
chose c'est que je sens que le lan titre
pis mme primaire qui anime tout le monde
nous fait oublier que dans sa vie pour
cent des français sont pour bailon mais
dans ce débat pitoyable on peut pas dire
que joe biden et brillé par son
intelligence son charisme et son sens de
la répartie
enfin je veux dire s'il était au même
niveau tous les deux et là encore une
fois on se canalise sur toi p moi je
suis ravi que trament dégage mais je
veux dire joe biden pendant ce débat a
quand même été d'une d'une nullité quasi
équivalente à celle de rester décent y
sont injurié tous les deux et à gueule
il devait tu n'es qu'un abruti je veux
pas tentant de parler est ce que tu vas
la fermer
voilà et là tout le monde dira
maintenant métro bagdad et maintenant
ces jo leinen été consternants venir
alors j'espère que kamala harris va être
sûrement très brillante
elle a aussi quelques casseroles
l'impression sur son passé et sa façon
de gérer le la cause de certains
prisonniers et certaines choses mais bon
chacun peut faire des erreurs mais c'est
aussi intéressant d'en parler et voilà
encore une fois je pense que la
démocratie ne gagne jamais à à noircir
complètement quelque chose et il
blanchit recrutement l'autre jambe à
l'autre celui là est tellement mauvais
que l'autre
peut être que merveilleux c'est
peut-être un peu plus compliqué que ça
et encore une fois je veux dire ceux
amis nous nous dit que le bail donne va
être merveilleux contre le co lead
contre les acolytes pardon j'en suis sûr
et je l'espère mais ça me paraît un peu
court comme programme économique et
comme programme pour la première
puissance des etats unis le lac au vide
c'est une chose voilà après s'il y avait
des recettes magiques
je pense qu'en france on s'en
serviraient et dans tous les pays du
monde donc peut-être que weiden à
quelque chose d'extraordinaire pour
lutter contre la copie
c'est encore une fois je le souhaite
mais au delà de la colite qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est ce que vont faire qu'est ce
que propose kamala harris qu'est ce que
propose joe biden c'est ça qui
m'intéresse parce qu est ce qu on
pourrait arrêter de trouver à chaque pas
un truc pour dire où la trempe emma est
moche de trump et machin tron peut
prendre les fins par la chatte c'est
fini ça vaut pas son autre chose parce
que sinon c'est une réelle celle des
choses certes non mais c'est il a dit ça
il ya cinq ans oui c'est pas comme eux
savent à quoi je viens maintenant est ce
que le débat est ce que les villas il a
dit je suis immunisé contre le contrôle
qu'ovide c'est quand même pas mal non
plus dans le genre déclaration tous
étaient les jours vous avez avec lui en
plus de la réduction de trump qui fait
il ressortir ces histoires de te prends
par l'achat pardon je le disais j'ai été
étonné qu un évangéliste soutiennent
quelqu'un qui disait ça c'était été pour
ça que je rappeler cette phrase juste
c'est pas pour tout le monde a des
trains pas comme ça s'était étonné parce
que cet attelage voilà un derby mais
peut-être sûr c'est à moi que vous
vouliez répondre aimé parce que vous
avez vous avez vu le débat oui mais en
fait on n'est pas obligé de prendre les
mots de tremper ya cinq ans pour voir
qu'il est complètement inapte à au
mandat qui lui a été accordé il suffit
de voir ce qu'il a dit la semaine
dernière la semaine d'avant il est est
immunisé contre le coc vide mais elle
n'est pas immunisée contre la bêtise et
là il a dit vingt quatre mille mensonges
depuis qu'il est président quatre ans le
discours d'un vente hier soir sur le
balcon il en a dit une vingtaine
en vingt minutes je pense que les
américains sont épuisés ils sont épuisés
par là le torrent de d'information et le
chaos qui est générée par
l'administration premiers veulent juste
du 15 mai ils veulent juste que ça cesse
peut-être juste pour rebondir rapidement
c'est vrai qu'en france nous on n'a pas
eu trop d'expérience comme ça de rejet
absolu d'un ancien président mais on a
connu une seule fois une campagne qui
s'est exclusivement cristallisée sur le
contre adversaires ça a été la campagne
de 2002 où on a eu jean marie le pen qui
est passé au second tour et on attend qu
jacques chirac y est passé avec un taux
record historique je crois de 80% ou
plus et c'est vrai que à la suite
justement de cette campagne contre jean
marie le pen où on s'était bien rendu
compte que ça n'a jamais été une
campagne pour jacques chirac un peu
comme on pourrait le dire de jo leinen
c'est à dire que c'est plus une manière
de sortir quelqu'un que de faire rentrer
quelqu'un d'autre et à la suite de ça on
a connu une présidence très alors on va
dire inutiles mais où président le haut
précisément il ne s'est rien passé et
peut-être qu'à ce moment là le pays en
avait besoin
et c'est vrai qu'en tout cas il y a des
moments politiques comme ça où le rugby
peut amener ensuite à une présidence
normale très apaisé voire même peut-être
un petit peu conservatrice et est un peu
molle puisque c'est ce qu'on lui a
reprochées par la suite mais il ya eu ce
temps de pause que finalement
démocratiquement on avait presque
réclamé donc peut-être que c'est ce qui
attend joe biden en tout cas c'est en
tout cas c'est ce qui s'est passé en
france et c'est le parallèle me semblait
assez frêle de raison de le faire cette
comparaison
juste un dernier mot on va passer à un
autre sujet mais la campagne s'est 3
milliards de $ par part candidat alors
ça c'est de la plus grande démocratie du
monde mais c'est une démocratie qui
coûte cher quand même ses fans
ça coûte cher mais tant qu'il ya de
l'argent - cc voilà enfin cet argent
serait peut-être peut sans doute plus
utilement utiliser à autre chose mais le
parallèle ici il est à faire avec
ce qu'en france nous et dans d'autres
pays
dans d'autres démocraties du monde au
demeurant nous nous nous essayons
progressivement brique par brique de
d'établir à savoir des règles à la fois
contraignant éclair de financement de la
vie politique de financement des partis
de financement des campagnes depuis en
gros la fin des années 1990 s'élabore
tout un corpus juridique qui clarifie
les choses alors qui est encore à
perfectionner mais qui depuis donc
l'époque requins en gros ne cesse de
produire des effets qui sont
fondamentalement de plus en plus
vertueux ce qui ne veut pas dire que
tout le monde est vertueux ce qui ne
veut pas dire que ces règles ne sont pas
signés des contrats mais il ya des
contrôles
il ya des contrôles qui sont de plus en
plus efficaces il ya un arsenal
juridique qui de mon point de vue était
indispensable notamment au regard du
financement des campagnes par des
personnes morales par des sociétés ou
par des puissances étrangères
tout cela est aujourd'hui en voie de
régulation on est à l'opposé évidemment
ce qui se passe à l'exact opposé de ce
qui se passe je me donnais tout le monde
peut donner sans aucune limite sans
aucune limite
m est porteur est ce que voulait
rajouter un mois tout ce qu'on a dit
parce qu'on va passer à un autre sujet
je signale que vous serez ici dans
quinze jours le 26 octobre
nous allons consacrer une émission
spéciale aux élections américaines
est-ce que vous lui joue le bout de la
conclusion et vous voulez sur ce sujet
je vais revenir dans coco vite de 30
maintenant il a quelque chose en commun
avec les 7 millions d'autres américains
qui ont été affectés c'est à dire que
d'ici quelques semaines il va perdre son
boulot et va être expulsée de sa maison
la maison blanche merci beaucoup et be
donc on se retrouve dans 15 jours vous
serez vous serez ici sur ce plateau
j'espère et je pense qu'il va se passer
encore pas mal de choses des 10 d'ici le
3 novembre
donc on aura beaucoup de choses à dire
merci merci infiniment
on a parlé de la guerre
maiden on va parler maintenant du
d'autres guerres qui se déclare c'est la
guerre entre les hommes et les femmes
[Musique]
alors vous le voulez emi nous on nous a
quittés puisque vous parlez maintenant
d'un sujet presque franco-français mais
quoique peut-être cette idée universelle
alors il ya plusieurs éléments il ya le
livre vous savez debladis coffin qui est
une ancienne journaliste qui est une
élue verte à la mairie de paris dit
monsieur qui s'appelle le génie lesbien
dans lequel elle prône au fond une
guerre contre les hommes est dit par
exemple moi les hommes je ne regarde
plus leur film je ne lis plus un livre
je n'écoute plus leur musique
il faut des illuminés de nos images de
nos esprits de nos représentations
donc elle c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez fort et puis il ya un autre
livre qui paraît que celui de pauline
armange qui s'appelle les hommes je les
déteste
voilà donc tout est dit je vous propose
peut-être de regarder d'abord un extrait
d'une interview d'alice coffin c'était
sur lci
c'est vraiment ton à ce que j'essayais
de faire dans les ccc d'aller dire
d'aller dire très frontalement ce qui se
passe et c'est ça qui est intéressant
dans ses compos même pas dire on n'est
même pas en train de répondre à la avec
leur art mal à la mesure du massacre qui
le commettent tous les jours pas du tout
on essaye juste de le dire et rien que
ça de l'énoncé ça pose un problème alors
le massacre qu'il couvait toujours dit
elle en parlant des hommes alors
évidemment on peut on peut se choquer on
peut on peut rire on peut avoir des
réactions
voilà par exemple je vais demander
d'abord peut-être à vous france et et de
charlène est ce que vous vous sentez
représenté par lyon par exemple par ce
discours pas du tout pas du tout je
pense que
ces deux femmes ne représente qu'elle
même et très peu de monde je pense pas
qu'il y ait un mouvement derrière cette
détestation des hommes
j'espère bien et j'ai comme le sentiment
quand on les écoute qu'elles ont une
histoire difficile personnel qui les
mène à ce stade que ça relève
certainement pas des féministes parce
que ce n'est pas du féminisme le fellini
c'est bien le contraire c'est justement
l'égalité homme femme et je pense que
ces voix là elle représente elle-même
est long mais un bouquin faut qu'elle
fasse du buzz pour vendre leurs bouquins
mais voilà elle représente pas grand
chose qu'elle intervienne non plus je
pense à français qu'à partir du moment
où on se définit en opposition c'est
précisément accentué la faiblesse du
genre donc a priori si je ne suis une
femme que parce que les hommes sont ne
devraient pas être des hommes ça veut
dire déjà que j'ai du mal à me définir
moi même et je pense que c'est
précisément l'inversé de ce que le
féminisme culturel a essayé de nous
apporter c'est à dire de se définir en
tant que femme comme un être humain
comme un autre et en essayant d'avoir
les mêmes droits donc je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait besoin d'autant de violence
et de caractère revendicatif à devenir
une femme épanouie aujourd'hui c'est un
message qui me fait peur aussi pour les
générations futures pour les petites
filles que nous sommes en train d'élever
qui ont à ce point là besoin maintenant
de sentir cette confrontation des gens
cette guerre des sexes qui a eu
évidemment ses vertus au moment de la
bataille pour les droits mais qui
aujourd'hui devient caricatural et
dangereuse c'est une bataille pour
terminer on est encore sur ce assure ce
séparatisme dans parle c'est à dire s il
ya une forme en effet de séparatisme
à voir juste avant de laisser la parole
à 20 cents cette femme est et ils ont
charles
c'est vrai qu'elle elle part de cette
réalité qui est celle de la domination
masculine et et donc son livre au fond
cette c'est un peu une théorie comment
lutter contre cette cette domination est
dit et c'est elle dit voilà il faut
aller moi j'ai été nourri jde lui que
dès que des bouquins d'hommes que des
philosophes sommes que des jeunes
écoutaient de la musique faite par des
hommes et il est temps maintenant de
changer c'est pour ça que l à cette
position radicales sur la domination
contre la domination masculine va sans
couronne qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je crois que cette saute et publié chez
albin michel qui est dirigée par un
homme
donc ça ça ne la dérange pas visiblement
mais ça c'est la domination masculine
qui voulait qu'elle y fasse
oui ou non elle ne lit pas les hommes
mais elle est bien contente de se faire
publier par un homme vous avez raison
cela dit il est dit sur des femmes kate
et qui a été échaudé femmes déviance
evans béton du féminisme dans les années
70 les dominations ou pas dans le monde
de l'édition que ce n'est quand même pas
mal il ya beaucoup de maisons d'édition
dirigée et tenus par des femmes et qui
marche très bien donc elles pouvaient
tout à fait peut-être que la valoir
n'était peut-être pas aussi considérable
dans d'autres maisons d'édition que
celui qu'on a dû lui consentir chez
albin michel ceci explique peut-être
cela
mais sinon au delà de la sottise 1
comment sera plus libre
et oui on peut dire que c'est ça qu'est
ce qu'il ya derrière ça pourquoi il ya
ce pourquoi il ya cette revendication
qui quand même intéressante
non je n'en vois pas l'intérêt il ya
suffisent à suffisamment de féminisme et
de féministes intelligente et de
discours sur l'action et le rôle de la
femme
sur l'égalité salariale à laquelle il
faut actuellement parvenir il ya
tellement de choses intéressantes et
tellement de chose intelligente et de
gens brillants et de femmes brillantes
et donne brillante qui s'exprime sur le
sujet que voilà accorder trop
d'importance à cette pauvre et lui me
voilà qui après s'être jeté comme une
cocotte comme un chien de chasse sur se
susurre christophe girard enfin avec
c'est pas avec ses panneaux lamentable
avec eux les mairies de la mairie de
paris qui sera un repaire de 2 p2 film
régler un problème de pédophilie a rimé
avec paris c'est pas si mal
chaque jour qui passe chaque jour qui
passe c'est cette femme ajoute une
pierre à l'édifice du mur de sa bêtise
bon voilà c'est le coup quand dire de
plus je franchement je ne sais pas la
domination masculine par la domination
féminine contrebalancer ces tests et je
veux plus lire et je veux plus voir et
je veux plus entendre cfe de
l'écrasement c'est un non sens je pense
que c'est pas du tout un problème
d'égalité dans ce qu'elle dit au
contraire je pense que c'est écrasé
remplacer cette domination masculine par
une domination féminine et ça je peux
prétendre y voilà et d'ailleurs mal mais
beaucoup de monde mal à l'aise puisque à
la maire de paris est elle relativement
mal et ça c'est plutôt salutaire des
gens qui m
elle parle aussi fine autre que donald
trump et dans un autre genre est ce
qu'on vous a fait les mariés et nous
réserve un petit mais c'est vrai que
quand on sait que des comparaisons avec
les islamistes afin de sa position avec
7 des islamistes à travers contre les
femmes ou d'eric zemmour enfin et on a
mis en parallèle
moi je trouve ça assez injuste
finalement vis-à-vis d'elle un discours
qui moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'est
ce qu'il ya derrière ce discours
qu'est-ce que pourquoi ce discours n'est
aujourd'hui vincent couronne disons
qu'on va être on va être complètement
d'accord
je n'approuve pas cette proposition
moment là et que ça soit séparatistes
communautarisme autres il faut être à
tout prix faire en sorte que certaines
femmes ne se referme pas sur une
communauté écluses it exclusivement
féminine en l'étant république nous
sommes tous et qu il faut arriver à
faire vivre cette égalité pour tous
simplement j'essaye de comprendre malgré
tout pourquoi justement est-ce que elle
prend cette position là moi j'ai un
élément de comparaison que je pourrais
donner c'est que on a connu cette même
tendance pendant des années chez
certains hommes aux homosexuels c'est à
dire une tendance à ne vivre qu'entre
simplement parce que le monde extérieur
était trop violent à leur égard c'est le
seul point de comparaison que je peux
apporter la lisons ski ski on l'a
effectivement qu'on dit jean-charles on
a des personnes très intelligentes qui
peuvent réfléchir à ces questions là et
qui peuvent nous explique effectivement
pourquoi est-ce que chez certaines
femmes il ya ce besoin de sécurité qui
se traduit par un repli sur sur
elle-même et le refus de de sortir je
pense que c'est aussi du comment on a
déjà parlé d'ailleurs sur le plateau a à
l'occasion de l'émission c'est aussi dû
au fait que il ya une image caricaturale
peut être dû aussi aux chaînes
d'information continue aux réseaux
sociaux etc sur sur le la place des
hommes dans la société et qu' il ya une
peur peut-être permanente et peut-être
désormais constante de chez certaines
femmes encore un ce n'est qu'il mûrit t
il florent s'adapte à raison c'est pas
elle ne représente pas normand sûr mais
il ne faut pas que ce mouvement-là
puisse s'étendre en revanche je pense
pas que lutter contre ce mouvement c'est
consisterait à le décrédibiliser
mais il faut aussi le comprendre pour
savoir justement comment faire pour y
apporter une réponse c'est valve vous
avons entendus sur ce sujet qu'ils ont
de la 6e de sa parole il y avait
plusieurs observations la première c'est
que je me félicite de vivre dans un dans
un système dans un pays dans une
démocratie pluraliste dans une
république dans laquelle il est possible
de publier ce genre d'ouvragé est
possible d'en débattre c'est pas le cas
dans tous les
dans tous les systèmes dans tous les
états du monde dans tous les régimes
une autre observation relative à la non
comment dirais-je à lalanne ont pensé à
l'absence de penser que représente cette
pseudo construction qui consiste au fond
à charlène le disais tout à l'heure à se
définir par la destruction de l'autre à
vouloir exister en détruisant l'autre et
le je trouvais que le numéro de mercredi
dernier du canard se dessinerait où elle
disait je ne je n'écoute plus de musique
écrite par les hommes je ne lis plus
littérature écrite par les hommes et à
l'avs est en face d'elle des islamistes
qui disait nous c'est pareil mais c'est
légal alors c'est une caricature mais la
position que qu'exprime alice coffin et
et sa comparse sont des positions l
honneur au mermoz sont des positions
elle-même caricatural et puis au delà je
sais tu as et vous avez raison assez
significatif de l'esprit du temps qui
consiste presque je rejoins ce que je
disais florence au fond à à se dire que
il faut aujourd'hui pour faire avancer
ses idées se situer dans la sphère de la
violence éviter de se situer dans la
sphère du débat qui n'apporte plus rien
je quand j'écoutais cela jeu quand
j'écoute son discours je je je me dis
mais c'est au fond la négation de ce que
représentait de ce qu'ont représenté
simone de beauvoir ou gisèle halimi qui
alors plus plutôt pour giza les limites
pour simone de beauvoir d'ailleurs avec
une direction face au handicap avait à
oui mais c'est raté avait avait une
vision très universaliste dans laquelle
le féminisme et et militaires le
féminisme était une revendication
d'égalité mais là nous sommes presque
dans une sorte de de dialectique
d'inversion davis ou d'inversion des
dominations l'inversion des listes
n'aboutit pas à la vertu et je pensais
en écoutant ce discours a par exemple ce
que le parti des indigènes de la
république sur d'autres sur d'autres
registres notamment des registres
proche du relatif au racisme mais on
n'est pas loin ici d'un racisme sexuelle
au fond d'un racisme quasi génétique qui
veut nier l'autre dans ce qu'il a de
plus de plus profond de plus honte aux
logiques kiki parti des indigènes de la
république qui condamne les mariages
mixtes entre les personnes de de détenir
ou d'origines différentes donc inverser
la domination n'aboutit pas à une
situation une situation vertueuse et
puis enfin jeu ça a été prononcé tout à
l'heure je pensais aussi à du point de
vue du côté académique et universitaire
à tout ce qu'ont apporté les études de
genre qu'ont été caricaturé en france
notamment à l'occasion de la campagne
présidentielle
du côté de françois fillon ont parlé des
théories du genre théorie du genre n'ont
jamais existé
c'était des études de genre dans
certaines universités américaines
étasunienne et puis un peu pris en
sciences politiques en sociologie en
france qui ont pas mal à porter de
nouvelles analyses c'est à dire des
d'analysé des faits sociaux sous le
biais de la différence sexuelle
bon mais c'est au fond je me dis
aujourd'hui que ce dogme du genre il
existe il est incarné par ces par ses
personnages par c'est de mon point de
vue par ces sinistres personnages qui en
effet ne parle que pour elle alors ça ne
me fait pas spécialement peur parce que
je dis qu'il est pas qu il ait pas il
est pas inutile et finalement d'essayer
de comprendre mais je je je me dis quand
même qu'on est là on sort complètement
de de quelque chose de rationnel on est
dans l'irrationnel alors une dernière
question sur ce sujet peut-être avec
internet et vincent yao fu de mouvement
c'est ce mouvement lesbien c'est celui
de l'affirmation du genre et on a notre
mouvement et stephan angers se faisait
l'écho à l'instant qui est celui de
l'indifférenciation sexuelle de mélange
des genres si je peux dire la confusion
des genres qui fait peur d'ailleurs
beaucoup de 2,2 fillonniste 2
qu'est ce que est ce qu'on est partagée
vincent entre ces deux tendances d'un
côté l'affirmation du genre et de
l'autre la confusion des genres je pense
qu'en fait on n'est pas forcément
partagé entre ses différentes ces
différents mouvements là je pense qu'il
ya trois tendances
il ya deux tendances assez radicale
celle de l'indifférenciation total et
celle de la de la séparation là aussi
hermétique et qui sont dus là encore une
fois l'organisation et la structuration
du débat a désormais qui fait qu'on
polarise les positions et que comme
comme stéphane et florent selon
directive mans il faut être radical pour
être pour être entendu donc ça fait que
ça fait que ces deux positionnements la
afe radicaux sont visibles dans le débat
en même temps il ya un troisième
mouvement qui étudie la complexification
de 2,2 le comment dire non pas de la
société mais de de notre évolution sur
ces questions là qui fait qu'on comprend
de plus en plus le rôle est justement
grâce aux études de genre le rôle du
genre comme le tse stéphane dans
certains dans certains faits sociaux et
que on comprend de mieux en mieux et que
cette idée là se diffuse de plus en plus
dans la société que il y à des
discriminations qui peut y avoir
certains métiers
certaines couleurs certains
comportements et c'est que l'on va
attribuer plus tôt aux hommes plutôt aux
femmes et qui en réalité les questions
de genre sont éminemment plus complexe
que cette simple dichotomie une femme
les hommes sont pompiers et les femmes
seront en infirmière et je pourrai une
culture vraiment la complexification
c'est ce ce sujet là ça n'est pas une
mauvaise chose
alan permane à un mois l'a d'ailleurs
c'est pas si vous avez eu la façade week
m'enfin ça existe depuis longtemps avec
saint laurent le l'unisexe dont la dans
la mode et de lorelei avait il y avait
notamment deux ou trois défilés qui est
qui et qui donne des dés des vêtements
masculins aux femmes
c'est vrai qu'on est plutôt dans cette
tendance-là de la confusion des genres
non en fait je suis un peu intérêts par
les deux mains sans parler comme des
extrémismes en quelque sorte et je suis
totalement d'accord je pense que on ne
peut pas se définir par une opposition
par principe est donc dès lors qu'on est
dans cette idée de nier le genre ou
d'affirmer le genre comme une condition
d'existence pour moi on est forcément
dans quelque chose de de mauvais à
apporter aux générations futures mois
moi ce que je retiens et qui me semble
être un peu dangereux c'est que le mot
d'ordre du féminisme de beauvoir et de
ce fait ministre que je qualifierais
myrick et de intentionnellement positif
pour les femmes
c'était d'élever des jeunes filles en
ayant plus honte d'être une femme mais
en ayant cette fierté finalement d'être
une femme au même titre que d'être un
homme
alors qu'aujourd'hui avec le balances
ton port avec le mythe ou avec ce
courant là et même avec le genre unisexe
on on est en train aussi de nier les
hommes et donc finalement on ne veut
plus que les petites filles naissent
fiers d'être des petites filles mais on
voudrait que les petits gars on est
content de n'être petit garçon et donc
je crois qu'en fait finalement on est
vraiment dans l' inverse du message
qu'on a essayé d'apporter dans les
années 50 et qui était un message
vraiment positif et apaisant à mon avis
un féminisme qui n'est pas un féminisme
combatif un combat pour les droits mais
n'est pas un combat contre quelqu'un et
à partir du moment où unisexe où la
bataille des sexes devient une guerre
pour détruire l'un des deux je crois
qu'on est profondément dans la négation
est dans quelque chose qui peut être
dangereux sur ce qu'on apporte à nos
jeunes générations donc montrons aux
plus jeunes que nous pouvons vivre
apaisé dans un monde dont nous sommes
différents précisément je crois que
c'est un peu ça con con qu'on essaye de
cataloguer avec le séparatisme c'est à
dire là le clivage des différences qui
en face des sections complètement
hermétique
les différences sont le socle de notre
démocratie de notre république givre en
commun
pas dire vivre tous pareils ça veut au
contraire dire qu'il faut que nous
soyons différents et que nous
respections n'oublions pas sa
l'universalisme c'est avant tout le
mariage des différences et à leur
négation vivons ensemble on passe au
vrai faux de vincent couronne alors il
ne reste plus beaucoup de temps
malheureusement mais vincent avec des
surligneurs vous vous décryptez comme ça
des propositions d'hommes politiques par
exemple ou qui sont inapplicables ou qui
ne servent à rien on peut commencer avec
la proposition d' emmanuel macron sur
les piscines des arrêts municipaux
réservant des piscines aux femmes oui
tout à fait patrice en parlant d'égalité
hommes-femmes que penser de ces mères
comme à grenoble notamment ou à à rennes
qui prévoit des plages horaires à la
piscine réservée aux femmes pour
permettre à celles qui par leur religion
ne peuvent se baigner en même temps que
les hommes et donc ne peuvent pas
pratiquer leur sport ou encore que
penser et là on sort de la question du
rapport homme femme de l'imposition de
menus confessionnels dans les cantines
scolaires et bien emmanuel macron a
proposé dans son discours aux mureaux
dans les yvelines sur ce qu'il appelle
le séparatisme de donner le pouvoir aux
préfets de suspendre les arrêtés
municipaux qui se fourvoierait dans
cette logique communautaire alors quel
est le problème ici le problème c'est
que cette mesure est absolument inutile
puisque des mécanismes existent déjà
patrice le préfet a déjà le pouvoir non
pas de suspendre lui même la décision du
maire mais de demander au juge
administratif de le faire à sa place
vous me direz oui mais la justice c'est
long sauf que là le justice prononce en
48 heures c'est le délai maximum
souvenez-vous dans la sphère de
l'interdiction du spectacle de dieudonné
le juge n'a mis que quelques heures pour
rendre son verdict c'est donc rapide et
sa fonction déjà on efface ici à
l'exemple typique de ce qu'est un effet
d'annonce une mesure fait pour montrer
que le président agit face au
communautarisme mais une mesure qui ne
servira à rien sauf à rendre notre
système politique encore plus complexe
en empilant des lois inutiles
très bien on a malheureusement plus
beaucoup de temps il y avait aussi mais
alors très vite cette idée qu'on peut
qu'on peut expulser les mineurs
étrangers isolés qui arrive en france
oui paris sera également très rapidement
effectivement le problème des mineurs
non accompagnés ou salles sont ses
enfants qui dans nos européens qui sont
en france sans leurs parents ni adulte
pour ce pour s'occuper d'eux eh bien
c'est un problème qui a ressurgi à
l'occasion de l' attaque devant les
anciens chaud devant les anciens locaux
parlons de charlie hebdo à paris le vice
président du rassemblement national est
aussi député européen jordan bardella a
proposé de renvoyer chez eux tous ces
enfants isolés
un voeu quasiment impossible a exaucé
car notre droit protège particulièrement
séminaire d'abord la loi française
interdit à l'expulsion des mineurs non
accompagnés
alors vous me direz il ne suffit que de
modifier la loi
1 sauf que la france a aussi signé et
ratifié une convention internationale
sur les droits de l'enfant qui
l'obligent à protéger ces mineurs isolés
on ne peut donc les renvoyer dans leur
pays d'origine que si c'est dans le
cadre d'un accord avec ce pays pour
permettre à l'enfant d'y être accueilli
dans une famille où une structure
adéquate au fond le critère principal
pour savoir si on peut ou non renvoyé un
mineur c'est l'intérêt super de l'enfant
jordan bardella le sait probablement
mais comment dire satisfaire sa base
électorale semblait être a visiblement
plus important merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup vincent contre je m'envoie
auront aussi des surligneurs évidemment
où on peut trouver beaucoup d'exemples
de ce genre voyez jean-charles on ne
peut plus rien faire c'est l'émission
terminée ma propre à ce débat avec grand
plaisir que j'ai choqué c'était pas de
bons sons internet bezina vincent
couronne et jean charles lajoie dit
lundi prêt à la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau prof
[Musique]